Puerto Rico as you may have heard is
under a hurricane watch this morning
with tropical storm Dori and now taking
taking aim at the Caribbean island right
now the bands of the storm were hitting
st. Lucia and st. Vincent people waited
in long lines Monday for food generators
and other supplies parts of the island
are still reeling almost two years after
Hurricane Maria CBS News climate and
weather contributor Jeff beard le is
here Jeff good morning what's the latest
storm track at this hour good morning
Tony good morning everybody yes so the
storm weakened a little bit overnight
it's still looking fairly impressive on
its satellite presentation here are the
stats winds are 50 miles an hour down
from 60 last night it's moving to the
west-northwest at 13 and basically right
over the Lesser Antilles this is a look
at the water vapor so right now the
storm is in a protective cocoon
however out here is a lot of dry air you
can see the dry air near Puerto Rico and
also some wind shear as well and so the
system is going to have to battle that
that's why we think it's probably gonna
strengthen a little bit but probably not
strengthen a lot before it reaches
Puerto Rico it's forecast to be a
high-end tropical storm maybe a low-end
hurricane either way you need to prepare
in Puerto Rico for a hurricane you want
to prepare for something worse than you
actually expect and on the eastern side
that's the wet side that's the windy
side and that's where Puerto Rico is
going to be notice that it could very
well kind of thread the needle move in
between the two islands right there if
it does it will maintain its structure
it'll have an easier time of reach
strengthening before it reaches the
Florida mainland as we head into
Saturday night and Sunday even though
it's forecast to be a tropical storm I
prepare for a hurricane Jeff thank you